قالت الشرطه التركيه ان المشتبهه بعلاقتهم
بتفجير اسطنبول قدامي كانوا يستعدون
لتنفيذ هجمات اخرى في مناطق تركيه مختلفه
وكانت سلطات التركيه قد القت القبض على
امراه قالت انها تلقت تدريبا من قبل حزب
العمال الكردستاني ووحدات حمايه الشعب
الكرديه ورفضت الداخليه التركيه تعازي
السفاره الامريكيه متهمه واشنطن بدعم
الارهاب شماليه سوريا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان هناك خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات كيف سنعكس تفجير
اسطنبول واعلان الاتراك عن ضبط شبكه تابعه
لحزب العمال الكردستاني على سلوك انقره في
جهه الحزب والدعمنا له ما الرساله التي
ارادها المهاجمون في هذا التوقيت وما
السوره التي بدات فيها الحكومه التركيه في
ضوء سرعه الاعلان عن القبض على المنفذين
والمرتبطين بهم وفي اي سياق نقرا رفض
الحكومه التركيه تعازي سفاره الامريكيه
بعائلات ضحايا التفجير
[موسيقى]
تفجير يخفي وراءه خطا لتنفيذ
هجماتها الداخليه تركيه على لسان وزيرها
سليمان صويلح الذي قال ان قوات الشرطه
احبطت تلك الخطط التي قال انها كانت
تستهدف مناطق مختلفه في تركيا
اكد ان العمليات التي تقودها الاجهزه
الامنيه التركيه متواصله بشكل ناجح
بشرني بالشكل الجديد
ولو لم نلقي القبض على الارهابيه لكان قد
تم تهريبها الى اليونان ومن خلال مكالمه
تعقبناها بعد التفجير يظهر وبشكل واضح ان
تعليمات التنظيم الارهابي كانت تملي بقتل
الارهابيه والتخلص منها تماما وهذا يشير
الى انه بقتلها سيتم منعنا من معرفه
ملابسات التفجير والهجوم لكننا لن نسمعها
بالتستر على هذا التفجير ومحوي ملابساته
ربما هذا الخبر سيحزن التنظيم الارهابي
لقد القينا القبض ايضا على الشخص الذي
امره التنظيم بقتل منفذته التفجير
حزب العمال الكردستاني نفع يكون مسؤولا
باي وجه من الوجوه عن الانفجار الذي شهده
الشارع الاستقلال في اسطنبول المتحدث باسم
الجناح السياسي للحزب زاكروس هو قال ليس
لدينا اي علاقه بالانفجار الذي وقع في
اسطنبول ولست مسؤولين عنه وقال بيانه
للحزب شعبنا والديمقراطيون يعرفون اننا
لسنا على صله بهذا الحادث واننا لا نستهدف
المدنيين بشكل مباشر واتهم الحزب الحكومه
التركيه بامتلاك خطه غامضه وباظهار كوباني
كهدف
وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان سويلم قال ان
نيابه العامه في اسطنبول اطلقت تحقيقا حول
الانفجار وكلفت خمسه نواب عاملين بالاشراف
عليه وعن تعزيه سفاره واشنطن لدى انقر في
ضحايا الهجوم
قالوا ان بلاده لا تقبل التعزيه التي
وجهتها سفاره الامريكيه عقب التفجير في
شارع الاستقلال وشدد وزير الداخليه التركي
على ان من يدعم المنظمات الارهابيه في
شمال سوريا هو من نفذ الهجوم ضد تركيا
نعرف الرساله التي ارادوا ايصالها لتركيا
من خلال هذا الهجوم
البيت الابيض قال في بيان له ان الرئيس
بيدا اعرب عن تعزيه العميق في مقتل سته
اشخاص جراه هجوم بقنبله في اسطنبول اضاف
البيان ان بيضا قال في اشاره الى تركيا
نحن نقف بجانب حديثنا في حلف شمال الاطلسي
[موسيقى]
مناقشه هذا الموضوع معنا من اسطنبول
الدكتور مسعود حقي جاشن عضو مجلس الامن
والسياسه الخارجيه التابعي لرئاسه
الجمهوريه التركيه ومعنا من ميرلاند
تشارلز كبشن عضو مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي السابق مرحبا بكما دكتور مسعود
حقي جيشن سنبدا معك كيف
سترد انقره على هذا الهجوم الذي وقع في
شارع الاستقلال
شكرا جزيلا
الارهابي الشديد وقد شنته منظمه حزب
العمال الكردستاني سوريا الارهابيه وقت
خطته ولهذا الهجوم ونفذوه من المهم جدا في
اختيار توقيت يوم الاحد وايضا في منطقه
جده وبالتالي فهذه منظمه ضد تركيا
والديمقراطيه وحقوق الانسان في تركيا 83
تقوم بتعاون كبير ودود قويه ضد الارهاب
واليوم واليوم نجد ان الثلاثه المشهورين
قد
الرفعوا العلم التركي
والدليل المقاومه الشعب التركي باننا لن
نستسلم ابدا امام الارهاب وان الشعب
التركي ضد كل انواع الارهاب وايضا ان
الرئيس التركي يقول باننا
لاننا لن نستسلم
العداله ونحاسب المسؤولين وشكرا جديد
ونشكر ايضا بشكل كبير ضباط الامن التركي
عندما تتحدث انه سيكون هناك ردود قويه ضد
الارهاب وان تركيا لن تستسلم امام الارهاب
ماذا نفهم عن طبيعه الرد التركي
استهداف الارهاب الدولي تركيا
يهاجرون النظام العبد وفي همم تركيا وان
تركيا تحاول حفظ العدل والقانون بيحاسبه
المجرمين وبالتالي فان هم كانوا يدنون
العرب
مباشر عن طبيعه الرد المحتمل التركي
باختصار لو سمحت نذهب الى ضيفنا تشارلز
اوك التركي
الرئيس اردوغان سوف نتابع المسؤولين
ونقدمهم العداله وثانيا هذا هجوم ضد
الكرامه والسياده التركيه والحياه
الديمقراطيه بالتالي فاننا نعرف ان هذا
الهجوم قد جاءنا من تركيا
ومن الضروري موجب القانون الدولي استعمال
حق الدفاع عن نفسه وهذا قلوب يعني انه
ربما تركيا عند الضروره سوف
العسكريين بالرد على هذا الهجوم همم
على مناطق السوريه
كيف يمكن ان تتعامل الولايات المتحده مع
هكذا رد محتمل شرحه لنا همم الدكتور محمود
حقي جاشن همم استعمال حق الدفاع عن النفس
كما قال لتركيا وربما تخول العسكريين الرد
على هذا الهجوم في سوريا
قلبي يتعاطف مع زميلي التركي فهذه فهذا
هجوم ماساوي وهو تراجع اخفاق في تركيا
خلصنوات الماضيه
لم تعرض هجمات عنيفه
ولا تنظيم الدوله وبالتالي الان يبدو من
التقارير ان ااه حزب العمال
هذا طبعا ياتي في وقت ما تتوتر
وامريكا وتركيا لم ترحب بالتصريح الذي
قدمته للسفاره الامريكيه
لذلك
لان التعاون مع الوحدات حمايه الشعب
الكردي هو الذي ايضا ان يرتبط
ولكن متحده
بشكل متحده
العامه تركيا هو التردد وتقصف المواقع
الكرديه في العراق في الشبه القنديل
واعتقنه سيكون هناك رد المشابه
لهجوم الذي حصل في اسطنبول
ان الولايات المتحده ستدعم ردا تركيا على
المنظمات الكرديه في داخل سوريا
سوريا
حزب العمال الكردستاني اي علاقه له همم
بهذا التفجير همم بعد ان همم اكدت سلطات
التركيه انه هو من دعم ومن يقف وراء هذه
الخليه باعتقادك لماذا لم يتبنى همم الح
فهذا هذا هذا هذه العمليه
شكرا جزيلا هذا سؤال وجيه للغايه انا
محامي وايضا متخصص بالقانون الدولي
منظمه ارهابيه بدون اي استثناء تتمارس
الاعمال الجرائم والعنف ونحن نعرف هذا في
التصريحات التي ظهرت من منظمات الارهابيه
اولا هم يغشون اخبار المزيفه ويقومون ليش
الدعايه السياسيه
في اسطنبول
منه
اعدادا كبيره بالناس
حتى الاطفال في اسطنبول
ان حكم القانون والديمقراطي وحقوق الانسان
وحتى وبفضل
الاساتذه
وفعنا اللايف متحد تدعمها وتعرفون ان
تركيا حروف الناتو او موجب الماده رقم
خمسه من النيته كل اعضاء النيته يجب ان
يحموا بعضهم الاخر والان في ان ان ان
هناك فتاه
في سوريا وان السيد
بعيدا سيكون لنا نقاش في هذا الموضوع قال
لنا همم تشارلز كبشن من ماريلاند انه
يتعين على الولايات المتحده ربما ان ترى
ادله واضحه ودامغه على تورط حزب العمال
الكردستاني حتى تدعم اي ضربه عسكريه او اي
رد تركي على هذا الحزب في داخلي سوريا هل
انقر مستعده لتقديم هكذا ادله للولايات
المتحده
اعيد واكرر قال لنا ضيفنا دكتور مسعود قال
لنا ضيفنا من ميرندا انه
يتعين ربما على الولايات المتحده ان ترى
ادله على تورط حزب العمال الكردستاني في
هذا الانفجار لكي تدعم اي عمليه عسكريه
محتمله على الحزب في سوريا
اوكي
جيدا الولايات المتحده ليست بقاضي فلماذا
نبعث بادله باللها هو اولا وثانيا
هو ايضا [__] الناس عندما اليوم من السيد
ان الشعب التركي يقرا نصا
حول الصحه السلام والعداله
وقد قال بانه حسن شعره بحسن الشديد نحن
محامين الدفاع المدني هذه المنظمه تقتل
الناس الابرياء وهم ينظمون هذه الهجمات
انطلاقه من سوريا
سوف يحاسبونهم نحن بالضر- لن نقدم اي ادله
نقدمها الولايات المتحده هذا اولا
والثانيه من من سيستعيد مواطنين ما سيعيد
حياه الاطفال الذين قتلوا هذه هذه الهجوم
وقع ضد الانسانيه وهناك ما اكثر
ارهابيه
وزير الداخليه التركي رفض التعزيه التي
تقدمت بها السفاره الامريكيه همم في انقر
على اساس ان من يعزي هي جهه داعمه للجهات
التي قامت بهذا الانفجار كيف يقرا هذا
الموقف في الولايات المتحده مصر صدى الذي
يخلفه في الاوساط السياسيه الامريكيه
صعبه
دكتور مسعود حقي جاشن كيف نفهم من جهه رفض
وزير الداخليه تلقي التعزيه من او رفض
التعزيه التي تقدمت بها السفاره الامريكيه
في الولايات المتحده على اساس ان الولايات
المتحده داعمه لمن يقفون وراء تنفيذ هذا
الهجوم ومن الجهه الثانيه اللقاء الذي جمع
اليوم الرئيس التركي
بالرئيس الامريكي في قمه العشرين والحديث
عن دعم صفقه طائرات اف 16
عايز
شكر خاص جدا
افضل حلقات
وفي العراق
لو سمحت جاوبني على السؤال من جهه رفض
لوزير الداخليه
للتعزيه من السفاره الامريكيه في انقره
ومن جهه ثانيه لقاء يبدو كانه ايجابي بين
الرئيس التركي والرئيس الامريكي في قمه
العشرين والحديث عن صفقه طائرات اف 16
اشرح لنا طبيعه الموقف الموقف التركي من
كل ما يحدث مع الولايات المتحده
مشاكل
الطائرات
فان الطائرات توافق على
التوفير هذه الطائره التي ضروريه لمصالح
الدفاع عن تركيا
والبيت ابيض
بان هذه اهم موضوع
واحد رغم ان تركيا تقبل هذه
فلما عندما نبكي عشان سبتمبر الرئيس
الامريكان
لثقد ثلاث الاف شخصا نحن بقينا لهم
ارهابي في امريكا
نحن قدمنا التعزيه
لكن اهم شيء في تركيا ان الرئيس اردوغان
قال نقبل التعازي من قبل
والثانيه وفضل سيد فايد هو مره اخرى كرر
الجزيره والتعازي المقدمه للشعب التركي
هذا التوقيت عن استمرار دعمه
لصفقه شراء طائرات اسسته عشر لتركيا بعد
تسجيل العقبات في الكونغرس كما نقي
السيد جاسم
الراي وهو اننا نخرج من منطقه صعبه في
العلاقات التركيه الامريكيه ولكن الان
نتجه في اتجاه نظري ان كانت هناك بعض
الخلافات والاختلافات حول تركيا الذي
الاصلاح عنده مجلس الامن القومي الامريكي
السابق وشكرا للدكتور مسعود حقي جاشن عضو
مجلس الامن والسياسي الخارجيه اتبع
للرئاسه لرئاسه الجمهوريه تركيا ضيفنا من
اسطنبول
الى هنا مشاهدينا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر شكرا لمتابعتكم الى
اللقاء
[موسيقى]